anime le Sénat sur le sujet des
territoires des élus des collectivités
et la seule excuse que nous avons pour
expliquer ce retard qui est le nôtre
mais vous nous en voudrez pas que soit
la passion et la conviction voilà euh
donc je voulais vraiment vous vous
remercier nous travaillons vous le savez
sur un sujet d'importance autour des
conditions de de l'engagement que
j'appelle un engagement civique dans la
plupart des cas la facilitation de
l'exercice de ce mandat particulier
d'élus local et tout particulièrement
des mais pas que et également sur un
volet dont on parle très peu qui est
l'après puisque l'engagement est une
parenthèse la fin de la parenthèse est
parfois choisie voulu et parfois euh
elle arrive un peu à l'insu de notre
plein gré si je puis dire un dimancheoir
parce que les les résultats ne sont pas
ceux que nous nous aurions souhaité donc
nous avons auditionné tout à l'heure des
des élus de territoires très différents
avec des témoignages remarquable et puis
là nous sommes très heureux de de vous
entendre en tant que représentant des
associations d'élus locaux ces
associations étant nos
partenaires réguliers quand nous
faiblissons les associations se
rappellent à nous activement voilà en
tout cas nous avons donc trois volets je
les ai bien expliqué tout à l'heure le
volet revalorisation des indemnités
considérant je le disais tout à l'heure
que la République n'a pas de prime elle
un coup et qu'aujourd'hui il faut
affirmer que l'engagement des élus doit
être sécurisé y compris d'une
manière financière en tout cas on doit
pas être pénalisé parce qu'on est élu
mais ce volet a été traité et nous avons
fait nos propositions donc aujourd'hui
nous vous
proposons à l'initiative
des corapporteurs qui sont là et que je
salue certains d'entre eux ayant dû
s'absenter vous savez on vote aussi le
budget en ce moment donc on doit ê un
peu
partout porte sur cette facilitation de
l'exercice du mandat et et et la sortie
et nous
avons donc cette mission flash sera
rendue dans sa totalité le 14 décembre
et le président du Sénat a annoncé lors
du congrès des
maires que le Sénat proposerait enfin
prendrait une initiative sous la forme
d'une proposition loin dès le mois de
janvier fort heureusement le mois de
janvier compte 31 jours donc on va
peut-être pouvoir le le le faire ainsi
mais vous voyez notre engagement et la
nécessité car nous voulons que avant les
prochaines élections de
2026 les choses est évolué et pour
faciliter l'engagement il faut que les
gens connaissent le cadre dans lequel
ils vont s'engager je rappelle juste de
chiffres que nous avons eu en 2020 une
centaine de communes qui n'ai pas de
candidats et que nous avons aujourd'hui
345 communes qui ont des conseils
municipaux incomplets et je ne parle pas
à des communes de plus de 3500 qui n'ont
eu qu'une liste lors des dernières
municipales il y a une
fragilité absolu sur ces sur ces
communes puisque il suffit d'une
dernière desmissions pour obliger un
renouvellement voilà donc je vous salue
tous en vos Grad et qualités AMF amrf et
je suis très heureuse de saluer aussi
intercommunalité de France qui est au
cœur de nos sujets puisque on sait et ce
sera mon dernier mot que quand on parle
du mandat d'élu local euh le mandat
d'élu local n'est pas que le mandat dans
la commune le mandat d'élus communal
mais il y a toutes les ramifications qui
aujourd'hui sont de plus en plus
exigeantes cell naturellement de
l'intercommunalité mais celle aussi des
syndicats je parlerai même pas des
scottes et cetera parce que euh voilà
chers amis donc Frédéric gric maire de
pégerol de l'Escalette sans doute la
plus belle commune de France président
des Maes de l'héro ça aussi c'est très
bien et co-président du groupe de
travail condition d'exercice des mandats
de la MF qui a fait un très gros travail
donc Éric crésel qui est maire de ces
fonds en haute Mar et membre du bureau
de l'AMRF voilà et nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion des des changés et les
apports sont toujours intéressants et
nous avons donc Fabien Jordan au titre
d'intercommunalité de France qui
effectue aussi un travail extrêmement
important autour des institutions et
vous êtes président de Mulous alsas
agglomération certains vous connaissent
très bien euh donc voilà vos vos témoin
et vos profils nous intéressent donc je
vous laisse la parole 5 minutes chacun
donc vous allez faire mieux que moi
ensuite la parole à à nos corapporteurs
et puis des échanges si vous le
permettez merci beaucoup donc je je
alors Monsieur R voilà c'est vous ça
vous
va très très bien
merci ne me demandez pas pourquoi il en
est ainsi c'est c'est l'arbitraire de la
présidente voilà très bien merci merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
les les les sénateurs mesdames messieurs
euh effectivement vous avez dressé le
tableau et le constat donc j'y
reviendrai pas on a instauré il y a 3
ans donc un groupe de travail sur les
conditions d'exercice du mandat et et
donc on a travaillé en plusieurs étapes
la première étape a consisté à beaucoup
écouter euh les témoignages euh beaucoup
enregistré effectivement et de voir un
peu comment tout ça s'intégrit dans le
dans le dispositif qui existe parce
qu'on dit le statut de l'élu mais il y a
pas véritablement de statut ici ou là
dans les différents ces et autres il y a
des éléments qu'on retrouve mais il y a
pas véritablement de statut et donc
cette première phase a permis de de de
d'aller vers les éléments que vous avez
indiqué c'est-à-dire les conditions
assez compliquées voire complexes voir
parfois assez dramatiqu pour des
collègues dans les territoires qui une
fois le débat démocratique de l'élection
estant passé se retrouveve confronté à
des réalités euh des missions des
compétences des obligations avec la
double casquette de représentants de
l'État et euh de représentants de leur
collectivité et et et et donc je vais
pas faire le Caliméro sur la question
des Finances qui sont un des éléments
quand même qui expliquent aussi beaucoup
une forme de lassitude et d'inquiétude
quant à l'avenir sur les conditions
d'exercice du mandat et donc on a bien
intégré le fait qu'il était important de
se préoccuper des des des trois phases
que vous avez évoqué avec deux éléments
de distinction les trois phases c'est
effectivement le début du mandat qui
pour celui qui vient de s'exercer moi je
suis rentré dans mon 5e mandat donc je
je j'avais un peu d'expérience
dirons-nous mais c'est passé dans des
conditions compliquées avec le covid et
dès le lendemain de l'élection un
certain nombre d'obligations à mettre en
œuvre euh qui était pas très très simple
et donc cuid de ses connaissances de ses
compétences des rouages du
fonctionnement des institutions des
obligations réglementaires de la
protection aussi de de de l'élu et puis
aujourd'hui on est à la mimandat donc il
y a effectivement le déroulement du
mandat c'est la deuxème étape on prend
ses marques et une fois qu'on a pris ses
marques on essaie effectivement
d'exercer dans les conditions que l'on
connaît son mandat et puis il y a
l'après vous l'avez dit qui est aussi
important parce que parfois ça crée des
des catastroph et les gens se retrouvent
dans des situations de précarité extrême
alors qu'ils ont consacré plusieurs
années au service de l'intérêt général
et de leur territoire et de leur commune
et sous-jacant à ces à ces trois étapes
il y a deux éléments qui sont importants
et qui nous paraissent important c'est
le statut c'est-à-dire l'élu en tant que
tel euh les autorisations d'absence les
créditurs vous l'avez évoqué les
indemnités la protection juridique les
questions de déontologie et cetera ça
c'est un un bloc et puis il y a le
deuxième élément qui est pour ma part
aussi important c'est vraiment les
conditions d'exercice c'est-à-dire une
fois qu'on a le statut comment on
s'organise comment on s'organise au sein
des intercommunalité comment on
s'organise pour Ben représenter la
commune en dehors parce qu' il y a l'
jeu interne de la collectivité mais on
sait bien qu'aussi beaucoup de choses se
jouent au sein de l'intercommunalité
dans les relations avec le département
avec l'État avec les institutions moi ce
matin à titre personnel j'ai posé une
journée de congé pour être là euh et il
y a 15 jours j'ai posé 4 jours de congé
pour pouvoir assister au congrès c'est
ainsi je l'assume je je m'en plains pas
mais il y a la vie
familiale et donc je je l'ai dit au
Congrès quand on met en parallèle ces
deux éléments c'est-à-dire la
personnalité l'élu en tant que tel qui
soit d'ailleurs maire ou conseiller
municipal ou adjoint et et qu'on met en
parallèle la vie de la
collectivité on est confronté à comment
on gère la désorganisation parce que
dans la vie d'un être humain il y a le
temps privé il y a le temps de la vie
professionnelle et il y a le temps de
l'élu et ces temps sont aujourd'hui dans
une journée de 24 he très compliqué et
donc on essaie d'organiser la
désorganisation c'est-à-dire comment on
se réparti et et on voit bien que dans
tous les constats et et l'étude qui a
été faite auprès des maires le démontre
bien c'est très difficile d'organiser
ces TR temps et donc là où il y a un
vrai enjeu et et et où j'en appelle à
votre à
votre intelligence collective si je puis
dire c'est faisons éclater un peu ces
tabout on demande pas des
privilèges vous l'avez bien dit je
partage ce que vous avez dit on n'est
pas là pour dire
les élus seraient une catégorie de
personnes privilégiées qu'il faudrait
protéger qu'il faudrait encadrer non on
a des responsabilités le suffrage
universel extraordinairement nous confie
des responsabilités euh donnons-nous les
moyens collectivement de les exercer
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
en protégeant nos personnes parce que
même si c'est un choix personnel dès le
départ euh une fois qu'on est élu ben on
se bat on s'engage on se on se défend on
défend nos territoirees on défend
l'intérêt général c'est ça qui est le
plus joli et donc on n'est pas là pour
pour effectivement
kémander des choses et donc il faut
faire voler ce ce baching qui peut qui
peut y avoir auprès de de de de nos
concitoyens pour justement redonner la
légitimité à l'élu qu'il avait il y a
quelques décennies et qui par tout un
tas de raisons aujourd'hui a été un peu
égratigé voilà merci à ce stade madame
la Présidente merci merci beaucoup euh
alors Monsieur crésel peut-être voyez
c'est un ordre qui peut paraître étrange
mais je vous dis
voilà je vous en prie il y a pas d'ordre
alphabétique voyez
là aucune offense mais je suis sûr que
vous n'en voyez pas merci madame la
Présidente donc Monsieur le Maire
effectivement le sujet dont on parle
aujourd'hui est très important pour
l'avenir pour pour la pour notre pays
pour la pour la République et donc nous
tous je pense à la fois on y réfléchit
et donc sur le fond donc c'est vrai que
je préside depuis 6 ans maintenant
puisque il y a eu la loi engagement et
proximité sur laquelle j'avais déjà
travaillé voyez on a déjà obtenu un
certain nombre de choses quand même
qu'il faut pas négliger mais par contre
pas le statut pas le statut lui-même on
a eu des morceaux dans dans certains
endroits qui sont qui ce qui éit
intéressant donc une
revalorisation plus forte sur les
petites communes que sur les autres
c'est ce qui était une démarche
intelligente donc voilà donc ENF qu' à
la fois on avait proposé on a forcément
adhéré du coup et donc je pense que tout
ça c'est important l'actualité donc au
niveau de la de la MRF c'est c'est le
question en 2023 en début d'année donc
on a fait un questionnaire puisqueon a
eu beaucoup beaucoup de collègues qui
nous ont sollicité qui travaillent dans
le
privé dans le public c'est un peu
différent c'est pas forcément toujours
facile mais c'est c'est différent et
dans donc on a eu un certain nombre de
collègues du privé qui nous ont fait
remonter un certain de questions donc on
a voulu prendre un peu de recul et on a
fait un questionnaire et et là et là on
s'est aperçu qu'il y avait vraiment des
questions très très importantes sur le
fond et euh qui donc des salariés privés
et euh dans l'angle d'entrée général
c'est qu'en fait au bout du compte si on
se dit
que pour forcer le trait personne du
privé peut être maire parce qu'on lui
donne aucune facilité du coup ça ça il y
a quand même une grande très grande
partie de la population qui sera pas
représentée au niveau des mairres et
donc c'est c'est c'est c'est donc une
une vraie question euh et c'est pour ça
que je commence par ça parce que en fait
dans nos
donc notre notre dernier congrès
donc début octobre on a donc validé 35
propositions donc je n'irai pas dans
dans toutes mais le deuxème article il
concerne le code du travail parce qu'en
fait au bout du compte il y a il y a le
le le contexte et comment on fait
c'estàd que si admettons que nous voilà
on fasse notre travail vous le vôre et
que il se passe un certain nombre de
chose et comme le collègue donc de Vand
là qui qui m'a dit mais de toute façon
moi mon entreprise elle regarde que le
code du travail
le CGCT sait pas ce que c'est donc
l'article
elle 111 je sais plus combien là donc
qui qui qui dit que on a le droit temps
d'absence et cetera et cetera ça
s'applique pas pour nous et donc voilà
je je je je souhaite commencer par ça
parce que du coup c'est c'est un enjeu
alors qui qui est qui est pas
directement lié sur sur le fond sur le
fonctionnement de l'élu mais par contre
du coup si on a pas ça du coup tout le
reste derrière est perdu donc voilà je
je je me permets d'insister de devant
vous sur sur sur cette question parce
que pour nous elle est au cœur du
système ensuite donc évidemment on a on
on a un certain nombre de propositions
par par rapport à l'exercice du mandat
donc le il y a la question des des du
volume
d'absence parce que le volume d'absence
en fait il a été fait donc je pense qu'
déjà il y a un certain temps sur la base
des disons des des des instances
statutaires voilà donc les conseils
municipaux les commissions et donc ça
veut dire que mais qu' qu'on ne peut
aller que là et alors dans un village le
problème le problème c'est que dans un
village toutes les commissions le
conseil municipal le CCAS enfin je sais
pas vous mais moi tout a lieu après 18h
voire 19h donc ce n'est pas dans les
horaures de travail donc cette ce droit
avec certain nombre d'heur donc quand
même c'est c'est assez important hein
donc euh c'est 35 he je crois pour par
trimestre pour une commune comme la
mienne qui est entre 500 et 1000 650
exactement
et donc du coup ça c'est un c'est c'est
c'est très intéressant mais je l'utilise
pas en fait par contre là où je
l'utilise et vous l'avez évoqué madame
la Présidente dans l'introduction c'est
que effectivement l'enjeu pour pour nous
maintenant c'est le zan le SCOT et un
certain n de choses donc ça veut dire
que il faut qu'on participe aux réunions
de de concertation
d'information de pour en en ce qui me
concerne aussi donc enfin limite des
interventions universitaires pour qu'on
a un peu de ul par rapport à tout ça et
donc tout ça c'est pas compté dans dans
dans le sujet et ce qui fait qu'on est
on est souvent démuni par rapport à des
cabinets qui viennent intervenir dans
dans dans nos collectivités notamment
dans les interc sur ces sujetsl et qui
donc son sont problématiques donc il
faut absolument qu'on qu'on traite cette
question de du volume d'absence et qu'on
identifie donc des enfin qu'on élargisse
et qu'on identifie les les ces sujets là
enfin pour l'exercice du mandat aussi il
y a la question de des des salariés
protégés donc qui que
en réfléchissant enfin en regardant un
petit peu ce qui se fait à la fois dans
les entreprises et par exemple sur les
pompiers donc il voilà il faut il faut
que que dans notre dans notre projet de
statut d'élu il faut qu'on qu'on qu'on
intègre cette question de de salariés
protégés parce que effectivement le mon
collègue là il a pris une journée de
congé moi aussi et donc il y a un moment
bah nos employeurs donc un moment les
employeurs des Mr
donc voilà don peuvent réagir et mal et
donc du coup il faut absolument qu'on
qu'on qu' qu'on traite cette question là
et c'est vrai que on a on a mis une
petite introduction donc c'est c'est nos
articles 8 et 9 là pour les sur les 35
proposition c'est à la fois informer les
entreprises qu'on voilà qu'on fasse une
petit label ou je sais pas comment il
faut l'appeler entreprise citoyenne que
les gens voilà vous vous avez un élu
parmi vous alors oui c'est vrai que de
temps en temps il prend des
demi-journées parce qu'il est obligé
d'aller à tel endroit mais peut-être du
coup il sait il sait parler en public
euh voilà il il comprend comment ça
marche et cetera et cetera et donc du
coup c'est c'est c'est peut-être
intéressant d'avoir quelqu'un comme ça
dans son entreprise après moi je j'ai lu
les gens qui trouvent que du coup c'est
c'est c'est c'est une compétition et
donc ça ça crée de la concurrence mais
voilà voilà donc ça ça c'est c'est
important sur le sur l'exercice du
mandat et bon a plusieurs sujets mais
Don je le dernier sujet don je vais
l'aborder donc c'est la question des
deux fonctions la la la la la fonction
donc de représentant de l'État et de de
de maire tout simplement qui a été élu
et donc donc je pense qu'il y a vraiment
cette question là et qui résoudrait une
partie une partie des questions
d'indemnité donc nous on avz
arbitrairement posé comme quoi il serait
intéressant donner une indemnité de 500
€ à tous les maires de France quelle que
soit la taille de la commune pour cette
fonction de de de de PJ et cetera donc
voilà donc et qui du coup dans les
petites permettrai donc de de ENF
d'alléger l'annité communale et donc de
régler cette question donc ça pourrait
être ça pourrait être intéressant et
l'autre partie faisant partie du mandat
donc voilà discuté mais la l'indemnité
ayant été augmenté dans la loi
engagement et proximité donc c'est enfin
c'est pas le cœur de de notre de de de
de nos
revendications je voudrais aussi aborder
donc la la question de
de de la
reconnaissance des communes puisqueen
fait la plupart des des enfin tous les
sujets on va dire parce que du coup jeis
en train de chercher maises j'en trouve
pas tout est basé sur le nombre
d'habitants et nous dans les communes
rurales le problème c'est que qu'un
moment on a tant d'habitants donc 200
pour lui 600 650 pour moi mais de toute
façon la question elle est la surface
c'est-à-dire que si on a des forêts
domanial si on on on a tout un tas de de
choses sur nos communes qui qui qui qui
nous prennent un temps fou et ça ça a
rien à voir avec le nombre d'habitants
donc donc et et voilà je pense qu'il
faut absolument qu'on qu'on qu'on qu'on
traite l'espace sachant que le tout
petit angle d'entrée par rapport à
l'espace juste pour appuyer là-dessus
donc c'est la c'est la question d'une
part kilomè²r c'est facile c'est facile
à calculer ça et peut-être l' l'angle
d'entrée des forêts puisque les forêts
ça nous permet de respirer à tous tous
les Français enfin tout même tout le
monde entier donc du coup voilà ça ça ça
nous permettrait de faire ça voilà donc
moi je je m'excuse peut-être un peu
dépassé je sais pas non non je vous en
prie ne vous excuse je vouis absolument
évoquer C ces différents sujets le
postmandat juste deux mots
effectivement on souhaite on a déjà fait
des petites démarches mais je pense
qu'il faut valider les acquis et à la
fois c'est valable pendant le mandat
mais après le mandat et donc par exemple
pour un sujet un sujet d'actualité donc
dans le cadre de village d'avenir donc
les les préfectures cherchent des chefs
de enfin des chefs de projet qui
accompagnent donc tout le monde tout le
monde s'est rué sur les enseignants
sortant de des des des licences et et
master donc sur l'administration
publique peut-être que un élu qui qui
vient de qui vient de sortir qui n'a pas
été réélu pour je sais pas quelle raison
à qui toutes les expériences pour faire
ça merci je vous remercie merci merci
beaucoup nous nous avons enfin tous les
collègues qui sont corapporteurs nous
sommes neufs hein sur ce sur cette
mission nous nous sommes emparés de
toutes les contributions qui ét qui ont
été faites par vos association qui sont
extrêmement importantes parce que nous
n'avons pas la prétention de réinventer
des choses que que vous présentez on
voit bien qu'il il y a une cohérence et
que chacun se retrouve dans les
propositions dans celle que vous avez
fait
juste un mot dont il est souvent
question ce qu'on appelle les aménités
rurales maintenant parce que c'est un
terme voilà un peu
chic et qui fait choc donc c'est parfait
et que au Sénat on porte beaucoup cette
question de la prise en compte d'autres
dimensions et pas simplement de celle
des habitants sans nier l'importance des
charges qui sont lié à la taille de de
la population mais effectivement il y a
des choses à réfléchir autour de et dans
les suggggestions dans vos questions
vous verrez qu'il y a déjà des éléments
qui ont été repris et juste un point
nous avons repris dans le premier volet
dont nous avons rendu pour lequel nous
avons rendu nos propositions sur la
revalorisation des indemnités des élus
nous avons dans les huit propositions
affirmé que l'État devait reconnaître de
manière sennante et
tribuchant l'indemnité en quelque sorte
qui doit à un élu qui en en quelque
sorte son salariés j'ose pas dire
clandestin parce que nous ne sommes pas
des salariés mais que l'état civil
l'organisation des élections et
l'urbanistme ce sont des tâches de
l'État et que nous nous avons clairement
indiqué ça monsieur le Président Jordan
très heureux que nous puissions parler
aujourd'hui de cet élément majeur du
bloc local qui est l'intercommunalité
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup je vais
commencer par me présenter donc j'ai été
élu en 2008 maire d'une petite commune
de 1200 habitants de le haurin à côté de
mulouse et euh j'étais ensuite président
de l'agglomération de mulouse en
succédant Jean-Marie beouquel
encesseur
voà en 2017 et réélu en 2020 je suis
également président de l'Association des
Maires du haurin on regroupe 100 % des
communes du du haurin donc les 366
communes et euh je vais raconter un
petit peu mon histoire parce que elle va
illustrer un petit peu euh notre nos
pensées nos idées euh je suis arrivé en
tant que maire je connaissais rien mais
alors franchement rien et je me suis dit
bah je vais être maire parce que je veux
m'investir pour l'autre euh je suis de
formation comptable mais aussi musicien
et donc voilà j'aime bien m'investir
pour l'autre j'ai toujours fait ça le
monde associatif voilà et je me suis dit
bah je je vais me sentir utile donc
j'avais pas d'expérience et je suis
arrivé j'étais élu maèire de ma commune
et ma première action c'était de fédérer
un peu tout ce qu' y avait autour de moi
fédérer toute l'énergie positive j'ai
mal dire et faire de telle sorte que ma
population que j'ai vraiment des acteurs
en face de moi et pas des consommateurs
et donc leur donner la possibilité
d'être acteur et que la collectivité
accompagne leurs initiatives et j'ai
ainsi créé la journée citoyenne à
travers l'observatoire national d'action
sociale dont j'ai pris la présidence à
la suite de Christophe Béchu et en fin
de compte c'était une idée toute simple
c'était juste rendre acteur nos
habitants et quand je suis arrivé à la
mairie la première question que je vais
poser
euh c'est de savoir où je pouvais faire
la formation parce que je ne savais pas
comment gérer la comptabilité publique
même si j'ai fait de la comptabilité
dans le privé je je voulais savoir où
est-ce que je pouvais placer mon argent
pour qu'il rapporte le maximum vous
voyez donc des questions comme ça et on
m'a expliqué que non non ça se passait
pas pas du tout comme ça j'ai dit ben je
vais apprendre et j'ai commencé à
apprendre et je pense qu'il faut qu'il y
ait déjà au départ une connaissance du
rôle du maire de notre mission parce
qu'on va voir aussi dans ce que je vais
dire que et vous le savez que notre
mission a totalement évolué ces
dernières années donc il faut qu'on ait
la connaissance il faut qu'on donne
envie aux jeunes de de de s'inscrire et
dans ce débat civique dans cet
engagement par la connaissance de du
rôle du maire et de son
engagement je pense que il faut revenir
à des valeurs et à cette proximité cette
réactivité la dynamique qu'on engage
mais aussi le côté exemplaire quand on
est élu ben des fois on dit des choses
mais aussi il faut faire ce qu'on dit et
s'il y a aujourd'hui
peut-être une cassure entre le monde
politique et les citoyens c'est que
peut-être on n' pas été suffisamment
exemplaire et donc nous les maires des
petites communes souvent on est beaucoup
plus exemplaire parce qu'on est en
proximité d'eux on les voit tous les
temps on et comme je suis maire d'une
petite commune et président d'une grande
interco je vois bien les différence donc
au-delà des des problèmes qu'on va
certainement aborder tout à l'heure qui
qui sont l'équilibre professionnel et
familial aussi la place des femmes
comment je peux faire en étant Maire de
famille pour m'engager dans un mandat
politique c'est un c'est un problème
supplémentaire et je pense qu'il nous
font cette vision féminine dans la
politique et l'après mandat comment je
retrouve une vie entre guillemets
normale est-ce que j'ai une valorisation
des acquis parce que j'ai acquis des
connaissances et pourquoi je peux pas en
profiter après et avoir peut-être un
poste qui me soit dédié au réservé ou
que je sois accompagné ou que mon
indemnité au moins elle soit en décret
chendo sur l'année qui vient pour me
permettre de de Me requalifier de faire
des formations enfin il y a l'avant il y
a le pendant et il y a l'après et il y a
dans l'évolution des communes la place
de l'intercommunalité aujourd'hui une
commune ne peut plus gérer sans
intercommunalité donc c'est
essentiellement aussi la place du maire
dans la gouvernance dans
l'administration dans le décisionnel
d'une intercommunalité une commmunalité
à notre sens elle n'est pas là pour se
substituer aux communes au contraire
elle est là pour accompagner les
communes je je compare souvent un grand
frère qui aide la commune à à faire des
projets à avoir la logistique aussi on
voit bien aussi qu'on qu'on a des
difficultés de recrutement des agents
l'attractivité des métiers n'est plus
celle qu'elle était il y a 10 ans on
arrive plus à emboucher on trouve pas de
secrétaire de mairie et donc là
l'intercommunalité peut mettre en en
place un système de mise à disposition
de secrétaire de mairie de logistique de
services juridique marchés public parce
que avec la gestion de
l'État tout devient plus compliqué euh
les marchés publics pour porter un
marché public dans une commune c'est
éminemment compliqué et on n plus non
plus la facilité et l'aisance et et et
l'autonomie financière qui nous permet
de faire 100 donc il faut toujours qu'
soit la quête de subvention ça aussi ça
demande un un grand travail au niveau
des services et dont on n'a pas la
compétence donc on a une réelle
dépendance financière euh déjà on la
taxe professionnelle on l'a plus ensuite
la taxe d'habitation et on a plus de
lien avec la population non plus donc il
faut trouver vraiment un système de
gouvernance global eu entre les communes
les intercommunalités qui facilitent
cela et euh on sait que 85 % des maires
sont aussi conseillers communautaires
ça ne va pas autrement on a mis en place
sur sur l'agglomération de mulouse une
réelle gouvernance de proximité des
maires et des élus locaux aucune
décision ne se prend sans l'aval de de
la conférence des maires et aussi chaque
fois qu'on a un projet important on a
des ateliers projets où participent tous
les élus municipaux donc au début on
m'avait dit que ça fonctionnerait jamais
parce qu'il y aurait beaucoup de trop de
monde parce qu'on a 904 élus municipaux
sur l'agglomération mais pas du tout
parce que quand vous leur donnez
possibilité de travailler il faut
travailler il faut l'assdité il faut
venir aux réunion donc et là vous avez
moins de monde mais au moins l'élu
municipal se sent concerné par la
problématique et par les compétences de
l'intercommunalité c'est comme un
transfert de compétenence un transfert
de compétence c'est pas pour faire à la
place de c'est pour faire avec et on
associe toujours un transfert de
compéten d'une charte et cette charte
elle dit que en fin de compte
l'agglomération va porter la compétence
mais s'il y a distorion de point de vue
entre la commune et l'agglomération
c'est le conseil municipal qui reste
souverain voilà donc c'est courageux
mais ça demande aussi la confiance qui
est là et la confiance c'est essentiel
et cette confiance il nous la faut aussi
des services de l'État qui sont pas dans
un rôle de facilitateur mais souvent
dans un rôle de complexité on n' pas la
considération qu'on mérite dans dans nos
postes parce que autant on peut bien
travailler avec les préfets et les
sous-préfets autant avec les services
quand même éminemment compliqué et j'ai
rarement rencontré un maire qui me dit
bah les services de l'État ils m'ont
vraiment arrangé là c'est depuis que je
les ai vu ça va beaucoup mieux c'est pas
tout à fait le cas voilà donc euh j'ai
j'ai naturellement sollicité l'ensemble
des mares pour avoir un peu leur avis et
on en parlera sûrement tout à l'heure
sur les différentes problématiques que
nous avons euh l'indemnité quelle est
l'indemnité juste d'amère estce que on
en parlait tout à l'heure parce que
c'est en fonction du de la population de
la superficie du budget euh des services
que j'ai comment est-ce qu'on la calcule
euh comment encourager les jeunes pour
que ils ils aient envie de venir dans
dans cette fonction là parce qu'on a
besoin de cette jeunesse les étudiants
comment est-ce qu'on va faire comment on
peut les intéresser mais juste parce que
il faut que nous on soit aussi fier de
ce qu'on porte au niveau de la
citoyenneté et les difficultés au
quotidien qu'on connaît tous et toutes
et et vraiment insister sur l'évolution
de la fonction du maire à travers le
transfert de compétences et toutes les
lois qui sont toujours descendantes qui
tiennent pas compte de la réalité du du
du terrain et une une bonne loi est une
loi qui puisse s'adapter en proximité et
je dis toujours que les bonnes idées
elles viennent du terrain et c'est
ensuite qu'il faut les construire
ensemble donc on est fervant de la
coconstruction et pas de nous imposer
des choses qui souvent manquent
réellement de bon
sens merci merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président on a
plusieurs demandes de parole alors
d'abord nos collègues rapporteurs Nadine
BO Guilen Pantel et notre collègue
Cédric chevalier et quelques-uns d'entre
nous avaient souhaité prendre la parole
tout à l'heure et on n pas pu le faire
donc n'hésitez pas à vous manifester
juste vous un mot vous remercier tous
les trois parce que nous sommes à la
fois un peu dans la technique c'est on
va parler revalorisation formation et
cetera très bien mais que les uns et les
autres vous avez beaucoup pas insister
sur le sens des choses euh c'est-à-dire
et c'est la démarche du Sénat c'est nous
ne sommes pas dans le volet technique
d'un statut nous sommes d'abord sur
l'affirmation euh que notre pays n'a pas
d'avenir si les territoires n'en ont pas
et s' n'y a pas d'élus et que les élus
sont des citoyens et que vous l'avez
très bien dit monsieur le Président et
les autres aussi c'est que nous nous
croyons que dans ce pays depuis la
Révolution la création de la commune il
y a quelque chose de formidable à
l'heure où on parle de la démocra e
participative il y a pas plus
participative que l'engagement d'un
citoyen qui peut
devenir le maire de sa commune et ça ça
a une valeur extrêmement précieuse et
qu'aujourd'hui il faut sauver je l très
calmement et paisiblement mais il faut
veiller à ça et que vous vous évoquez un
élément qui est extrêmement important à
prendre c'est-à-dire vous évoquez que la
relation avec les services de l'État
tout ça c'est très important pour
faciliter le mandat donc nous n'aurons
pas de propositions très concrètes
là-dessus mais c'est un écosystème et
nous avons a travailler sur la
déconcentration c'est la proximité des
services de l'État cette idée de
décentralisation qui est pas ici à Paris
quelqu'un ah ça va être très bien on va
donner ça au département non non c'estàd
on part des demandes et des besoins des
territoires pour construire c'est
comment nous nous faisons des lois des
possibles et non pas des lois
d'obligation des lois d'interdiction
donc tout est dans tout et vous évoquez
un point les collègues il reviendront
sûrement qui est extrêmement important
c'est celui de
l'intercommunalité et qu'aujourd'hui
vous le
savez nous partageons tous le fait que
il y a beaucoup de communes qui sera en
grosse difficulté s'il a pas
d'intercommunalité et qu'il n'y a pas de
sentiment d'intercommunalité de rejet de
l'intercommunalité à voir on est loin de
ça et qu'en même temps si je puis dire
on voit aujourd'hui des difficultés
apparaître dans les conseils municipaux
en raison je dis pas à cause mais de
l'intercommunalité qui parfois étaé
forcé dans son péri parfois a pris des
compétences qu'on devrait pouvoir
traiter un peu en subsidiarité et que on
a une vraie difficulté pour les maires
dans des des interc où le maire est le
seul représentant de la commune et que
le maire se sent parfois écrasé quand
l'interco est grande et que le maire à
ceci de terrible c'est qu'il est la
victime expiatoire quand il revient dans
son conseil municipal et qu'il doit
expliquer que la décision a été prise
mais que lui il est tout seul parmi 140
et que moi je suis très sensible à ce
que vous dites sur la manière dont on
doit avoir un infectio sociétatis et en
tout cas être dans cette relation
positive d'un principe de
subsidiarité mes chers collègues
oui merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
merci messieurs vos témoignages euh
juste nous dire euh si vous identifiez
des difficultés puisque vous n'en avez
pas parlé mais c'est c'est un sujet qui
nous est revenu est-ce que vous vous
identifiez vous est-ce que vous d'abord
vous pensez que c'est assez connu et je
pense souvent aux petites communes aux
communes de de de peu d'habitants euh
les difficultés concernant conflit
d'intérêt et le fameux déport euh
lorsque des décisions doivent être
prises parce qu'il nous revient que
c'est quelque chose de pas forcément
très très bien connu et pas très bien
appréhendé sachant que tout ça n'est pas
d'ailleurs très bien
défini merci madame la Présidente et
merci pour vosre témoignage combien
important et puis puis on se retrouve et
dans toutes les auditions que nous avons
faites on retrouve énormément de de vos
propos moi je voulais vous parler alors
par rapport à vous
monsieur la MRF le représentant de la Mr
euh par rapport voilà je voyais pas
votre nom excusez-moi euh la
reconnaissance de l'élu même dans
l'entreprise ne faudrait-il pas qu' a
une charte avec passer avec avec
l'employeur ou pour avoir euh comment
dirais-je le même le la même
reconnaissance que ce qu' un pompier
dans une entreprise quoi parce que l'élu
n'est pas du tout dans au contraire il
dérange bien souvent une entreprise
privée ou publique que quand on a un
pompier ne serait-ce qu' un délégué
syndical il a il a absolument toute
toute manœuvre en fa comment dirais-je
toute liberté possible que les élus non
on est
toujours on est toujours avec un regard
différent donc est-ce qu'il ne faudrait
pas peut-être faire une charte je ne
sais pas ou
un engagement quelconque par rapport à
son employeur public ou privé de petites
petite entreprise c'est encore plus
difficile mais dans les grandes
entreprises publiques c'est pas mieux
quoi la plupart du temps donc voilà
c'est
c'estci merci Guilan donc Gérard la
rapporteur breton oui merci madame la
Présidente
messieurs merci pour vos contributions
vos éclairages vos indicateurs de
connaissance donc je suis sénateur des
côes d'Armor et corapporteur donc de la
mission que j'ai qualifié parce que moi
le le propos
permettez-moi comment être après avoir
été autrement dit que devenons-nous
quand nous ne sommes plus
élus mission compliquée que j'ai eu à
vivre un peu je vous fais grâce de ma
modeste
expérience mais à la lumière de cette
expérience je me suis dit
que nous savions en France être
prescriptif quand il s'agit de nous
imposer des normes mais c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué quand il s'agit de
conforter ce qu'on appelle un statut ou
une
situation donc voilà
donc dans cet
univers j'ai besoin de quelques
éclairages parce que parmi la diversité
des
élus nous avons tous besoin de quelque
chose c'est l'objet de ces trois de ces
trois
rapports nous sommes très divers nous
n'avons pas besoin de la même chose et
nous avons aussi des élus qui ne
demandent rien et ça ne veut pas dire
que le problème n'existe pas donc on est
confronté à cette complexité à ça
s'ajoute aussi la complexité juridique
vous en avez parlé un peu c'est de plus
en plus difficile de plus en plus
compliqué et euh il me semble
que nous avons
besoin d'un accompagnement des
élus lorsque pour des raisons diverses
ils ne le sont plus et quand je dis
l'accompagnement c'est au sens large au
sens juridique bien sûr au sens
social au sens de la protection aussi
vous savez les conflits d'intérêt on
avait un témoignage tout à
l'heure ce sont des on peut être exposé
à des précarités juridique pour des
raisons totalement indépendantes de sa
volonté et alors je me pose la question
de l'instance qui serait la mieux
placée pour organiser ou pour proposer
cet
accompagnement voilà je je me pose cette
question là à l'heure où je vous parle
et du coup je considère que vousos
éclairages nous seront grandement utiles
merci merci beaucoup Gérard chers
collègues
messieurs qui veut répondre d'abord je
vous en prie
allez-y Monsieur le Maire alors et comme
vous l'êtes tous pour pour répondre donc
de façon pragmatique sur sur le conflit
d'intérêt
effectivement on a mis en place dans
dans beaucoup de territoires le référent
déontologu h et donc c'est un élément
qui est fort important puisque dans la
plupart des départements en tout cas les
communes avaient l'obligation à la fin
du mois de juin de cette année donc de
mettre en place un un référent
déontologue et donc euh nous dans les
Ron on l'a fait à l'chelon départemental
on a désigné trois personnes C qualité
euh bon il y a pas plétor non plus de
cesine donc ça renvoie un autre débat
sur ce sujet-là mais il y a
effectivement aujourd'hui un dispositif
qui permet aux élus d'M avoir une
réponse au-delà de l'avocat conseil
parce que souvent l'avocat il raisonnait
sur l'aspect risque de contencieux euh
voilà et et pas nécessairement sur le
fond et les valeurs qui fait qu'à un
moment donné euh est-ce que le Petitfils
il peut rentrer à la mairie pour faire
un stage est-ce que ma femme qui
travaille dans une entreprise qui a
soumissionné au marché public et cetera
et vous avez bien vu que les juges en
matière de contentieux n'ont pas fait de
cadeau puisque des mères ont été
condamnés au motif qui n'était pas
sortis de la salle du conseil même
n'ayant pas participé au vote avec des
situations assez voilà donc ça c'est le
premier élément référent déontologue
mais je renvoie aussi à la formation qui
est un élément qui est essentiel euh au
début du mandat et pendant le mandat
parce
que on a on a parlé lors du congrès de
la simplification du DIF et du fait que
le le DIF n'était pas du tout ou très
peu utilisé et j'ai cité un exemple dans
lesé Ros il y a 40 ans on a créé un
syndicat M mixte avec le département et
les communes et les interc qui fait de
la formation forme plus de 1500 élus par
an sur l'ensemble des poirségaliens en
s'appuyant bien sûr sur des experts
c'est de la formation action c'est très
simple les gens il cotisent au syndicat
et gratuitement on leur rend plus de 50
demi-journé de formation par an et donc
j'avais invité les les membres de de de
de l'atelier à venir s'il le souhaitait
expertiser ça et donc ces questions de
déontologie et de risque de conflit
d'intérêt peuvent être traité aussi sur
l'aspect de la
entreprise cumule charte effectivement à
un moment donné euh on a beaucoup de cas
j'ai j'ai en mémoire un maire qui
travaillait dans une entreprise de
travaux publics qu' é manutentionnaire
et il se retrouve maire et donc il gère
les marchés publi il refait tout son
village la voirie la VRD et il se
retrouve en conflit avec son patron
parce que effectivement il lui dit mais
toi tues mère tu conduis tu te tais
c'est pas parce que tu es à la mairie
que tu sais mieux que quiconque
organiser et préparer les chantiers
alors qu'il avait une expertise tout à
fait considérable qu'il avait acquise
dans ses missions au quotidien et donc
effectivement là il y a vraiment un
sujet de de de d'articulation et puis
sur les instances d'accompagnement je
pense que les association d'élus euh
dans l'accompagnement ont un rôle il
existe des instances comme les centres
de gestion ou les CNFPT par exemple hein
qui peuvent peut-être avoir des des des
missions d' accompagnement parfois c'est
le Centre Hospitalier Régional qui
devrait effectivement se préoccuper
parce que l'accompagnement psychologique
d'élus qui se retrouvent dans des
situations de détresse et de tension
extrême pendant le mandat mais aussi
après le mandat on n'est pas là pour
témoigner de de la vie personnelle mais
moi j'ai été confronté à ça on se
retrouve au pied de mur et on est seul
au pied de mur avec sa famille et ses
amis et donc parfois se faire aussi
accompagner médicalement et
psychologiquement c'est aussi des des
éléments qui qui me paraissent
importants et puis dernier élément euh
c'est la question du pouvoir
réglementaire euh on est dans un pays
effectivement où malgré les lois qui
sont votées on sait bien que derrière
les décrets les circulaires les les et
les et les arrêtés préfectoraux sont pas
tout à fait toujours dans l'esprit de ce
que le législateur a voulu mettre dans
la loi et donc là il y a vraiment un
sujet qui renvoie à la question de la
crédibilité de la lé intimité du pouvoir
de l'élu comment on peut contester une
délibération qui est prise par une
instance qui a été démocratiquement élue
au motif qui un petit point une virgule
dans une circulaire que personne a vu et
qu'un fonctionnaire de mer ou d'ailleurs
a prise et qui va s'appliquer parce que
le principe de précaution d' y a une
vingtaine d'années a malheureusement
fait que on est confronté à des
administrations qui cherche plutôt à ne
pas faire qu'à laisser le pouvoir de
l'élu à essayer de faire et donc ça
renvoie effectivement à cette légitimité
qu'on doit pouvoir avoir et au poids
qu'a pris aujourd'hui le pouvoir
réglementaire dans l'action
publique de de deux évocations
Guilen Pantel parlait du sapeur pompier
volontaire nous avons au Sénat enfin au
Parlement de manière générale adopté des
dispositions spécifiques en bonification
de retraite par exemple pour les sapeurs
pompiers volontaires mais aussi la
reconnaissance de de l'engagement
civique de l'entreprise qui accueille
des saeurs pompiers volontaires et c'est
une
interrogation que nous avons et puis
juste un mot alors c'est pas la
complainte du parlementaire mais je suis
très heureuse que les maires eux-mêmes
disent qu'il arrive que l'administration
contrarie le législateur et lesesprit
parce qu'il arrive même que l'on voit
des décrets d'application sortir que
nous-même nous ne comprenons pas parce
que nous disons mais on n'a jamais voté
ça et que nous avons fait des
propositions dans un groupe de de réfle
son conduit par le président Larcher euh
et dans le rapport sur la meilleure
fabrique de la loi où nous nous
suggérons que les rapporteurs
c'est-à-dire les sénateurs ou les
députés qui ont porté le texte au nom du
Sénat soient associés à la rédaction des
décrets d'application pour qu'on
explique bien à l'administration ce que
nous nous avons décidé que
l'administration est censé appliquer or
parfois les rôles se confondent je sais
pas si euh l'un de vous cher cher euh
oui merci madame la Présidente donc oui
peut-être introduction pour rebondir sur
ce que vous avez indiqué tout à tout à
l'heure sur la sur la la
citoyenneté et donc le le rôle des élus
et c'est vrai
que je sais pas mes collègues mais on on
est quand même enfin agacé pour le moins
par rapport au fait que si on est élu on
se fait agresser oui beaucoup d'élus se
font agresser donc le c'est c'est que
c'est important c'est grave il faut
accompagner il faut que les associations
d'élus quand même accompagnent donc
voilà tout ça c'est grave mais par
contre il faut aussi donner l'autre
volet et l'autre volet il est manquant
alors donc on essaie chacun faire de nos
sujets donc par exemple nous de de sur
sur une période de 15 jours là et que on
renouvellera en début d'année donc
tout on fait petit des petits séquences
de 2 minutes on demande à la mère
pourquoi pour pourquoi tu tu es m et
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu tu retou
voilà je vais simplement faire ce petit
sujet là il faut travailler sur les sur
les sur les deux sujets pour la question
du conflit d'intérêt euh donc
effectivement enfin c'est c'est assez
bien connu donc le comme le collègue en
a parlé
euh moi je avec les collègues mais de
proximité sur l'intercommunalité où je
suis en échangeant c'est surtout le
deuxème niveau c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
au bout du compte la plupart des maires
ont quand même bien compris ce qu'il
fallait pas faire mais par contre et ça
m'est arrivé moi aussi dans mon conseil
les les conseillers les habitants ils ne
comprennent pas et donc on prend des
volets de bois vert parce queon n pas
pris l'entreprise de de la commune parce
qu'on a respecté la loi et donc donc on
on a donc on est du coup extrêmement
isolé en tant que maire parce que nous
en tant que maire on appelle loi mais
les autres gens du conseil donc eux il
tout ça voilà ça leur passe audessus et
voilà donc le conflit d'intérêt pour moi
il il est plus en terme de de de de
pression dans dans nos petites communes
et surtout queon a un lien direct c'est
des petites entreprises donc on y a un
lien direct on a toujours quelqu'un de
la famille ou de proche qui qui qui est
dans le conseil donc voilà donc c'est
quand même ça extrêmement dur à gérer
plus que le fait de de de pas savoir
enfin où est la limite et cetera je
pense que les la plupart des mères font
quand même attention
euh sur la question de de la relation
aux entreprises donc oui enfin
effectivement qu'on l'appelle entreprise
citoyenne comme nous ou une charte
d'employeur c'est c'est effectivement la
même idée je pense que c'est très très
important et mais là aussi pour un peu
sacraliser c'est peut-être un terme un
peu fort mais euh je pense qu'en début
de mandat le fait par exemple d'être de
de d'instituer le maire enfin de voilà
de de le mettre c'estd que bon après je
sais pas si le préfet il aura temps de
en H Marne de de rencontrer les 425
maires mais euh je sais pas comment
quelle est la formule mais que voilà que
que en début de mandat on
institutionnalise ça donc ça veut dire
que toutes les entreprises parce que il
y a des collègues quand même qui euh
n'osent pas dire à leur entreprise qui
sont élus hein il y a quand même des
gens qui qu c'est des entreprise un peu
avec des succursales un peu grandes et
cetera il y a a des entreprises qui ne
savent pas qu'ils ont des élus dans
leurs effectifs donc voilà donc je pense
qu'il faut avancer on peut on peut que
que que s'améliorer sur cette question
là et je pense que c là aussi ça ça
participe disons au mandat de de enfin
au mandat aux possibilités de de de de
2026 donc oui peut-être
pour d' des petit point
oui c'est par rapport à ce que ce que ce
que vous indiquez sur sur les les
les questions du mandat donc quel par
rapport à la complexité moi je voudrais
insister sur la question de la santé on
a on a on a lancé un travail là-dessus
pour par rapport à la santé tout
simplement le le comment on résiste à la
pression et et des maire et donc je vou
voà que par rapport à ce que vous avez
indiqué sur le comment leprès et cetera
et cetera ça agit sur le mental des des
élus et donc c'est très très important
Mo je reviendra après peut-être mer
merci beaucoup sur le volet
psychologique il en a été question tout
à l'heure je pense qu'il était tradition
que les mares soit formé aux finances à
l'urbanisme enfin voilà et que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui vous savez le gignn
d'ailleurs a mis en place avec les
associations de M des formations à la
gestion de crise mais je pense que
l'accompagnement psychologique est
extrêmement important on parle beaucoup
des situations d'agression mais pour
ceux d'entre nous qui ont été maires il
nous est arrivé à tous hélas de devoir
aller annoncer un décès de gérer une une
situation très difficile et moi je me
souviens quand j'étais président de
l'Association des maires de mon
département comment notamment une femme
maire avait été profondément enfin vous
voyez choqué une sorte de traumatisme et
on avait organisé avec des médecins des
psychologues des des
psychiatres au niveau de la soci une
formation et un accompagnement pour
donner quelques clés essayer de survivre
ça parce que c'est une pression qui est
très forte monsieur le Président et
ensuite notre collègue Cédric chevalier
que je n'ai pas oublié
alors je vais regrouper un peu le tout
je veux dire en règle générale il faut
qu'on fasse plus confiance au maires on
a vu que pendant la crise sanitaire que
les mares étaient en capacité de faire
c'està dire c'est pas quand c'est décidé
quand c'est centralisé et vertical que
c'est efficace c'est quand on est sur le
terrain que c'est efficace parce qu'on
est dans la proximité et on a ce bon
sens qui nous permet de faire donc
laissez-nous faire donneznous les moyens
de gérer on a les responsabilités mais
donnez-nous aussi les moyens donc en ce
qui concerne la la formation on a quand
même mis en place aujourd'hui un système
très complexe de l'identité numérique
qui nous décourage pour ceux qui avaient
encore envie de faire une formation de
la faire c'est juste pas possible parce
que le temps qu'on s'inscrive c'est
juste pas c'est pas gérable et donc
laallocation est de 400 €os par an et
donc en fin de compte qui est versé à la
Caisse de dépôt de consignation si on en
utilise moins il y en a qui l'utiliseent
à à notre place c'est pas mal aussi pour
eux mais peut-être moins bien pour nous
donc il faut qu'on revienne à quelque
chose de simple encourager les gens à se
former je pense que c'est important
donner une visibilité de ce que c'est
que la que cette fonction de maire avant
pour que les gens qui se présentent a
envie de se présenter en disant bah
voilà ce que vous serez amené à faire
quand vous serez maire présentez-vous
aux élections vous avez la possibilité
de faire et que après qu'on a une sortie
qui accompagne les maires pour leur
trouver peut-être des postes parce
qu'ils ont acquis des compétences et
c'estes compé on peut pas les perdre
parce que c'est l'expérience qui est
importante excusez-moi je veux rebondir
parce que on a une idée comme vous
parlez de de de de la formation l'idée
d'inscrire une journée par mois
d'absence pour les maires d'accord et et
qui voilà serait remboursé en fait par
l'État h à
l'employeur estce que cette idée de
toute manière à la fin c'est toujours
une question d'argent parce que même
quand on dit que je suis pas sûr que
l'État soit d'accord ah
ben voilà il faut aussi que quand quand
on dit qu'il faut revaloriser les
indemnités que quand les entreprises
doivent être reconnues elles doivent
être citoyennes mais aussi il faut que
quelqu'un prenne en charge on voit bien
chez les sapeurs pompiers moi j'ai mis
des ces doubles engagements en place
dans ma commune bah c'est l'entreprise
en fin de compte qui qui fait l'effort
et personne ne fait à la place de
l'entreprise donc quelque part souvent
on veut pas dire qu'on est élu parce
qu'on a peur que après on sera sera pas
embauché parce que on sera très souvent
absent donc c'est c'est plutôt ça donc
au niveau du conflit d'intérêt c'est un
réel problème au niveau de la
présentation des délibérations si je
maintenant une délibération sur une
subvention attribuée à un musée ou un
équipement si je suis élu en charge de
je n'ai plus le droit parce que je fais
partie du conseil d'administration de ce
musée donc c'est pas moi qui présente la
délibre c'est quelqu'un qui connaît rien
ou alors on laisse l'administration
gérere et donc du coup on fera plus rien
du tout et l'élu je lu dit écoute c'est
sympa mais tu peux pas trop en parler
malgré tout ce que tu as fait non c'est
c'est pas respectueux du travail qui est
fourni donc c'est un système qui ne va
pas donc on essaie un peu de de filouter
un peu on fait des trucs on fait voilà
donc il quitte la salle après mais voilà
il aurait dû partir avant il aurait pas
dû écouter le ENF voilà ça tient pas de
bout voilà donc là-dessus sur la Form
sur la formation j'en ai parlé les VAE
pour la sortie voilà je je je pense que
c'est vraiment et pour la la la crise de
vocation je pense ça fait aussi partie
de tout cela cette possibilité de faire
et de valoriser quelqu'un dans l'action
qu'il
porte juste vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de de comment est-ce que les
faire en sorte que les femmes
s'investissent un peu plus voilà ça
c'est aussi un vrai sujet parce que
parce qu'il y a un pourcentage très très
faible
encore merci madame la Présidente donc
merci aux différents intervenants
euh moi je je je viens pour l'amont et
pour l'après en fait sur sur l'amont on
revient sur le sur l'histoire de la
formation euh mais à entendre et
d'ailleurs ceux qui vous ont précéder
euh il y a pas forcément une
appréhension réelle de ce que ce que
peut être euh élu au sens conseill
municipal maire adjoint et cetera
euh et je fais un parallèle c'est que
que aujourd'hui dans les dans les
entreprises ceux qui une certaine taille
qui ont un CSE la loi permet à des
salariés de prendre des
congés payés d'ailleurs par la par
l'entreprise pour pouvoir se
former pour savoir s'ils peuvent se
présenter au CSE c'està qu'en amont pas
d'être élu mais en amont ils peuvent le
faire donc je m'interroge sur le fait
que à un moment donné cette disposition
qui permet permettrait de dire à
n'importe qui de prendre une journée ou
deux et pas plus parce que on il peut
être beaucoup plus élevé payé par
l'entreprise permettrait de faire cette
première formation ce premier levier
pour pouvoir appréhender ce qui'est la
fonction d'élu je le dis d'autant plus
parce que bon je suis chef d'entreprise
et cetera mais il faut à un moment donné
aussi arrêter c'est que beaucoup de de
chefs d'entreprise ou autres vous disent
aux élus vous êtes hors sol vous êtes
déconnectés vous connaissez pas ce qui
est le monde l'entreprise oui d'accord
mais si vous ne favorisez pas le fait
que des salariés des chefs d'entreprise
puissent s'engager dans la vie publique
vous allez avoir cette déconnexion donc
à un moment donné il y a un élément
d'effort à faire euh partager ça c'est
le premier point donc ça c'est la
question sur finalement est-ce que cette
d'ailleurs quand vous réfléchissez bien
je trouve que j'ai jamais trouvé de
formation à devenir élu c'est je sais
pas vous avez des formations qu' vous
l'êes mais pas avant bon donc euh c'est
c'est le premier point et la sortie la
sortie euh euh je trouve que finalement
de s'être engagé pour la
collectivité pour le pour le bien commun
bah finalement ça doit être valorisé
parce qu'effectivement on l'a entendu
tout à l'heure il y avait la prise de
parle en public la la gestion comptable
la capacité à mener à manager une équipe
et donc ça c'est des vraies compétences
qui ne s'acquierent pas comme ça au
travers d'un diplôme moi la
problématique c'est que la
Vee je vous invite à ceux qui on en fait
une enfin je pense qu'on veut partager
c'est une usine à gaz c'est une vraie
usine à gaz parce que ça correspond pas
forcément donc voilà ça c'est c'est le
premier point et de le financement de
cette VAE le le sujet c'est que quand
vous êtes sorti vous ne rentrez plus
dans le scope des de financement
obligatoir des collectivités de
formation donc à un moment donné euh
vous dites bah j'ai donné et puis bah en
sortant bah je je veux traduire mon
expérience et bah non seulement c'est
une usine à gaz mais en plus
financièrement c'est pour ma pomme
donc voilà donc je pense qu'à un moment
donné il y a peut-être aussi à ce que
vous savez dans dans certaines
entreprises on provisionne pour les
retraiter et cetera ben que dans la
ligne budgétaire formation on
provisionne aussi quelque part
l'accompagnement de C enfin c'est une
idée mais en tout cas on n'arrivera pas
à un moment donné à à valoriser ce
travail si concrètement on dis qu'est-ce
qu'un élu et toutes les compétences qui
va avec mais aussi derrière cette
traduction universitaire et cet
accompagnement financier dans les
aujourd'hui vous pouvez devenir boucher
fleuriste ce que vous voulez mais ça
pour non mais c'est c'est une réalité
mais pas être élu voilà donc c'était ma
remarque par rapport à
ça un mot sur la prise illégale
d'intérêt qui est un vrai sujet parce
que je je disais tout à l'heure un jour
un conseil municipal ne pourra même plus
voter la taxe d'habitation puque enfin
elle existe plus donc le problème
supprimé mais le foncier parce que
lui-même est propriétaire ça devient UBS
puisque'il y avait de la prise illégale
d'intérêt de public à public comme ce
que vous évoquez donc ici au Céna on
apporté deux dispositions qui améliorent
un peu l'une dans 3ds et la deuxième
dans la loi justice parce que il y avait
nécessité de faire bouger la loi mais on
a encore un certain nombre de
difficultés et ça c'est un vrai sujet
même si vous l'avez dit nous avions
souhaité la création enfin un accès à un
déontolog log et vous en parliez très
bien qui doit permettre aux élus de
pouvoir être un peu sécurisés quand ils
font
euh des choses même si vous parlez
beaucoup de l'empêchement de faire des
élus vous avez raison mais je pense
qu'il y a à la fois de la norme du
décret d'application un peu tordu par
rapport à l'esprit du législateur mais
on a un problème de société avec la
judiciarisation et donc la recherche de
responsabilité ce qui fait qu'une
administration alors pour si au Conseil
national d'évaluation des normes moi je
suis assez fasciné c'estàd
l'administration prend des tas de
dispositions pour que rien n'arrive donc
en soi c'est rien de contrariant mais au
final rien n'arrive du tout c'est-à-dire
y compris l'action qu'on est censé faire
parce que on a essayé de surprotéger de
sécurité donc il faut aussi faire passer
des messages auprès de nos concitoyens
en disant nos concitoyens qui attendent
beaucoup et qui voudrai pouvoir avoir
satisfaction de tous leurs besoins
personnels c'est-à-dire en gros rentrer
à l'école à l'ORS où ça les arrange pour
chercher leurs enfants le soir et en
même temps ils veulent de la sécurité
donc le maire il doit fermer les écoles
on a aussi euh ce sujet euh euh
totalement difficile sur la formation un
petit mot dans 3ds on a on va dire euh
un peu nettooyer le dispositif de
formation qui euh comportait beaucoup
d'abus euh puis puisque la formation
était ouverte aux élus mais on avait des
choses qui à mon avis ne sont pas
nécessaires on va le dire comme ça pour
être politiquement correct et surtout
très excessif donc l'idée a été parce
qu'on dépensait beaucoup d'argent pour
très peu d'élu sur des formations
parfois très
créatives donc on a essayé de comment
dire de
rendre le marché un peu plus
sain mais quandme en même temps on a
inventé un dispositif de procédure
d'accès qui est exactement ce que vous
dites c'est-à-dire l'autre jour dans une
commune UNL moi ça m'a pris 3 jours tu
comprends il me fallait en plus mon
identité numérique fallait que j'aille à
la poste donc moi c'est terminé je le
fais plus et seul l'élu peut le faire
enfin c'est un truc de fou et que on a
moi j'ai écrit à la Caisse des dépôts et
coniliation qui l'opérateur qui m'a
expliqué que tout allait bien bon très
bien on a alerté la DGCL qui m'a dit que
non non sans que ma question éit un peu
fondée et moi je souhaite vraiment qu'on
puisse au sein de la délégation à un
moment faire une évaluation du nouveau
dispositif de formation qui a été mis en
PL pour faciliter l'accès c'était juste
les deux points un peu techniques que je
voulais dire je vous en
prie je je je je pouvais juste rajouter
un un un mot sur les entreprises je
pense que il faut vraiment considérer
l'entreprise qui fera le pas il faut la
labelliser une entreprise citoyenne il
faut officialiser la chose pour que
l'entreprise aussi bah existe et du coup
est valorisée par son action et du coup
ça lui fera aussi du bien elle se
sentira considérée comme les élus qui
font une action donc je pense que ça
c'est important et euh pour la la la
présentation de de du du rôle du maire
qu'il y ait euh une petite formation une
petite euh qui est faite pour tout tous
ceux qui veulent être candidats pour
lexpix qu'est ce qu' vont être amenés à
faire et ça leur don en cours plus envie
de le faire donc ça je pense que c'est
important et ensuite au niveau du
citoyen je pense qu'il y a quelque chose
qui est important quand on parle de
considération je pense qu'on devrait
rendre obligatoire l'inscription dans
les mairies quand vous habitez dans une
commune je veux dire il est il est
inconcevable pour un maire d'accepter
que quelqu'un vient habiter dans sa
commune on n plus de lien de
fiscalité s'il est propriétaire on sait
on sait rien du tout de ce qu'il fait et
il vient juste pour se plaindre à la
commune et ça devrait être l'inverse
donc je pense que il y a le droit et les
devoirs et on inverse souvent les
choses sur sur la question de de du
conflit d'intérêt de de la déontologie
vous avez raison moi j'ai j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec les référents
déontologues donc de notre département
et en fait il s'appuie sur le premier
élément qui est la charte de l'élu et la
charte de l'élu elle a le mérite
d'exister donc loin de moi l'idée
d'apporter la la moindre critique mais
entre la charte de l'élu et l'exercice
au quotidien de la fonction d'élu il y a
il y a un espace assez vaste qui peut
même devenir euh immense euh et donc du
coup il y a effectivement un équilibre à
trouver pour éviter de tomber dans la
question de la
juridaciration parce que pourquoi en
fait euh le déontologue une fois qu'il a
analysé la charte de l'élu la situation
et cetera il va regarder euh ben la
jurisprudence des tribunaux il va
regarder les contentieux qui qui se sont
euh déroulés sur des situations et
cetera et puis après il va trouver un
équilibre par sa personnalité en
essayant de conseiller il amet un avis
auprès de l'élu qui après ben fera la
part des choses donc il y a vraiment un
travail assez précis à mener
effectivement pour identifier un certain
nombre de de de de situations parce que
aujourd'hui tout est contencieux vous
l'avez dit Madame la prés idente et donc
effectivement il faut pas que ça
devienne un frein à l'action publique
moi j'étais assez inquiet quand on a mis
en place les référennéontologue sur le
fait qu'effectivement il y a
suffisamment de choses pour la
trouille avec en plus ayant rajouté
celle-là qui fait qu'à un moment donné
vous allez toujours regarder derrière
vous pour essayer de de vous dire est-ce
que j'y suis j'y suis pas et donc à un
moment donné il y a la légitimité du
statut de l'élu de sa de sa de son
conseil municipal de la manière dont il
organise les les décisions et de sa
légitimité effectivement à agir dans
l'intérêt général il faut pas oublier
qu'on agit dans l'intérêt général et
quand on fait des enquêtes publiques on
les fait pour l'utilité publique et
quand on prend une délibération on le
fait dans le cadre de la loi pour
l'intérêt général et cetera donc il faut
revenir à les fondamentaux et je pense
que peut-être ça nous éclairerait assez
sur effectivement une forme de périmètre
dans lequel on pourrait ou pas agir sur
la question effectivement de de de
l'accompagne
par rapport à l'emploi le secteur privé
public dans dans notre groupe de travail
et et on pensait à la MF que ce serait
intéressant aussi de travailler avec les
syndicats professionnels
euh les les chambres l'interconsulaire
en fait pour
effectivement au plus haut niveau ben
regarder effectivement comment avec leur
accompagnement il est pas question de
déséquilibrer des des salariés j'ai
souvenir d'un chez l'entreprise qui me
dit mais tu comprends sur un éch faudage
c'est pas parce que le type il est maire
qu'il va pas faire du ciment et donc il
a le droit de faire du ciment je dis
mais c'est pas du tout le sujet au
contraire même d'ailleurs c'est le
premier qui devra le faire pour montrer
l'exemple de ce qu'il fait dans toute la
commune et si on regarde la situation je
pense que c'est le premier qui le fait
voilà c'est une petite anecdote mais je
pense qu'il faudrait faire mener un
travail effectivement avec et puis
pourquoi pas également c'est une piste
qui avait été évoqué avec pour l'emploi
dans le cadre effectivement de
l'accompagnement euh à la fois pendant
ou ou ou ou ou après parce que
effectivement il existe des conseillers
pour l'emploi pour le RSA il existe des
conseillers pour l'emploi pour tel type
de catégorie et cetera mais je dis pas
qu'il faut créer un charger de mission
pour l'emploi élu mais quelque part
c'est quand même des particularités et
et et du coup ça renvoie la question euh
je je partage assez ce qui a été dit par
Monsieur le Sénateur sur le le le le
rendu de la VAE d'abord c'est une
démarche qui est lourde qui est longue
qu'on n pas toujours le temps de le
faire quand on se présente c'est pas
pour être battu aux élections d'après
donc on n'est pas nécessairement dans
cette réflexion et plutôt dans la
défense de notre quotidien et donc
est-ce qu'il y aurait pas une réflexion
à avoir sur les examens professionnels
euh ou des des validations d'acquis mais
beaucoup plus simple qu'une démarche de
VAE qui partirait peut-être sur une
volonté de l'élu à s'engager dans telle
chose et telle chose parce que c'est
pluompéten hein mandat d'élu euh et donc
en fait c'est pas parce qu'on est élu
qu'on est polytechnicien si je caricatur
un tout petit peu mais pour autant il y
a des élus qui sont plutôt penché sur
tel type de domaine sur tel sur tel
autre et cetera et qui voilà pendant le
début de leur mandat pourraient
effectivement réfléchir mais il faut
être accompagné c'est pas le DGS c'est
pas le
directeur de la des services de la de la
comcom et cetera je crois que c'est
vraiment un travail qui qui est
spécifique et puis euh enfin il y a
quand même un élément qui est chouant
aussi c'est que sur nos frontons il y a
liberté égalité et il y a fraternité et
si on travaille sur ces questions de
condition d'exercice du mandat la
question de la fraternité il faut pas
l'oublier
quoi pas celle de la laïcité parce que
çaouvrirait encore des débats un peu
longs on y passerait l'après-midi mais
mais je pense que la question de la
fraternité c'est peut-être un sujet sur
lequel effectivement il faut qu'on
travaille collectivement le Parlement
les associations d'élus pour essayer de
remettre ça aussi au cœur de la mêlée
quoi la fraternité c'est quand même une
des valeurs de notre République et on
l'a un peu oublié j'ai l'impression on
l'a dans le discours public mais après
dans l'action au quotidien et être maire
c'est aussi être dans la
fraternité merci merci beaucoup
euh juste peut-être comme ça en écho à
ce que vous dites sur la validation des
acquis je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
chemin de croix qui n'aboutit que
rarement et que l'idée qui est creusée
par les collègues qui sont sur ce volet
de l'aprèsmandat c'est d'avoir des
sortes d'équivalence et on sait qu'un
adjoint à l'urbanisme un adjoint en
charge des ressources humaines il a
acquis des compétences qu'on est capable
d'identifier il y aurait une sorte de
correspondance voilà c'est il faut
vraiment qu'on ait des choses souple qui
soit réel et simple monsieur le
Président et vous aussi Monsieur le
Maire vous avez évoqué quelque chose qui
est essentiel on peut faciliter
l'engagement des des des élus nous
allons le faire et le sécuriser mais
pour ça il faut aussi peut-être d'abord
et toujours et encore après éveiller au
civisme et à la citoyenneté et que moi
je suis très sensible à ce que vous
dites et ça a été évoqué par nos
collègues ça participe aussi de la
formation des élus c'estàdire il faut
qu'on ose dans ce pays faire des
campagne de communication sur ce qu'est
un élu enfin on on parle de triez vos
déchets manger des fruits légumes c'est
formidable mais est-ce qu'on peut aussi
à un moment montrer vous l'avez dit vous
le faites des petites témoignage d'élus
en voilà c'est très important parce que
on Nura pas d'élu si on n pas non plus
de citoyenneté donc de fraternité c'est
très clair et sur le sujet que vous avez
évoqué très justement le lien avec
l'entreprise nous nous allons
proposer à la délégation enfin au bureau
la semaine prochaine de parler du maire
employé c'est le maire qui est salarié
et nous voulons nouer un dialogue avec
les associations professionn
patronal et nous allons faire ça en
binôme avec la délégation aux
entreprises ici au Sénat parce que nous
pensons que nous avons aussi des
messages apportter auprès des
entreprises et que dire qu'à un moment
on a une sorte de crédit d'impôtou
d'exonération de charge parce que
l'entreprise a en son sein un salarié
qui contribue euh à tenir la République
enfin disons le voilà ça nous semble
extrêmement important donc on va faire
ce travail au premier semain mais il
faut aussi qu'on dialogue avec les
organisations professionnelles pour
qu'elles comprennent que toutes celles
qui aujourd'hui se lance dans la
RSE c'est très bien mais que je pense
que si vous avez un salarié élu c'est
quand même un engagement très fort en
matière de RSE
monsieur le le maire je vous en prie
oui je voulais préciser aussi dans dans
dans la démarche effectivement pense que
c'est une démarche globale à plusieurs
volets la question des relations aux
entreprises il a effectivement la la
formation en amont et donc je je l'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure mais je le redis
par rapport à la question des salariés
protégés et donc voilà on poursuit pour
l'instant j'ai j'ai rendez-vous encore
la semaine prochaine avec le cabinet de
Monsieur duopt pour pour sur cette
question parce que pour nous
effectivement elle est très importante
et je pense qu'il faut il faut en fait
additionner ces différents sujets à la
fois les que les entreprises via VI les
di puisse former former des gens en
amont de de de ce sujet là donc je pense
que c'est
vraiment je pense que c'est très très
important et que on a sûement une
réflexion à faire pour de façon plus
générale former les gens aux questions
d'élus parce que c'est vrai qu'on a on
on a des questions on a envie de faire
répéter aux gens répétez-moi la question
parce que tellement que ça a rien à voir
avec nous donc tellement ils savent pas
ce que ce que ce qu'on doit faire et
quel est le périmètre de notre de notre
fonction et donc ça c'est quand même
c'est quand même une vraie question je
vrais revenir quand même sur la question
de la formation euh parce que
effectivement dans dans le cadre de la
loi engagement et proximité là j'ai j'ai
découvert et donc dans une conversation
un peu tendue on va dire avec la caiss
des dépôts et la
DGCL j'ai découvert que la la formation
était
euh facilité ou je sais pas comment faut
dire pour les communes de plus de 3500
habitants et que donc il y a un texte
qui disait que voilà donc les les
formations j'ai demandé donc à la DGCL
mais pourquoi et ils ont dit mais on
peut pas faire euh on peut pas
multiplier le processus par 36000 donc
on l'a multiplié par 3500 et donc voilà
c'est plus simple et ce que je veux dire
c'est que dans dans dans les morceaux
non non mais je caricature c'est ma
façon de parler je m'en excuse je m'en
excuse mais donc et vous avez raison on
a effectivement essayé de clarifier
cette question là à cette occasionl mais
je je je le redis parce Queen fait au
bout du compte il reste des petits
morceaux de de de choses un peu comme ça
qui qui nous porent préjudice au
communes euh parce que donc on a on a
mis des des espèces
de plancher du coup je sais pas comment
fait dire ou plafond il y a un moment
une forme de limite et qui qui porte
préjudice donc aux communes et donc ça
c'est c'est c'est une vraie question et
sur la sur la question d'élus plus
généralement pour rebondir sur la
question de mon collègue sur la
définition enfin VAE pas VAE et cetera
c'est vrai que on est un peu dans dans
le enfin dans l'hypothèse enfin je sais
pas si on peut comparer mais du médecin
généraliste c'estàd qu'à la fois on est
on est généraliste mais spécialisé dans
un domaine qui est la vie publique et
cetera et cetera mais donc voilà on est
on est on est sur sur ce sujet là et
donc du coup c'est difficile à définir
mais il faut absolument qu'on qu'on qu'
qu'on travaille qu'on forme les gens
mais qu'il y ait aussi une formation de
de façon plus générale pour le
l'ensemble de la population je
voudraisre un mot sur la formation
pardon
excuse-mo oui non je voulais dire je
voulais simplement un dernier mot sur la
la question de
l'évaluation de de mettre des des cadres
a par exemple donc l'évaluation qui a
été faite récemment sur le le coût des
des élus
c'est surtout que moi ça ça m'évoque une
une vraie question qui est une
différenciation par rapport aux petites
communes et aux grandes communes alors
les petites communes les grandes
communes on discute c'est à partir de
quand pour moi il y a qu'une définition
c'est directeur général des services ou
pas pour moi il les petites communes
c'est celles qui n'ont pas de DGS les
les communes plus grandes c'est ceux
qu'en ont un et si on fait des salariés
cadre A dans les communes si il y a un
salarié qui est maire et un salarié qui
est DGS je vois pas comment le binôme
peut fonctionner donc voilà je voulais
simplement alerter sur cette question
enfin je c'est c'est juste je vais faire
une petite parenthèse sur C ce sujet
merci beaucoup de mettre ce sujet au
débat la formation est aujourd'hui enfin
je pense un enjeu mais aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment un mur infranchissable et que
on voit sur la question de l'accès à la
formation et du coup euh moi je je vois
de plus en plus les interc proposés
euh aux élus communaux qui le souhaitent
et aux communes de mutualiser des
actions de formation par ça coûte moins
cher on est dans la proximité et que
cela contribue très fortement à créer du
lien entre les élus donc à
apprivoiser l'interco et à échanger des
compétences et à découvrir que dans tel
commune il y a quelqu'un qui a une
expertise et que donc ça donne vraiment
très souvent puisque tout ça c'est c'est
volontaire ça ça met en exer la valeur
ajoutée de la
mutualisation et en valeur ajoutée
qualitative et ça je pense que ça peut
être une une réponse extrêmement
intéressante pour l'accès à forction et
surtout pour créer du ciment et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président parce
que nous on sent
qu'aujourd'hui c'est terrible mais quand
on les enquêtes qui ont été faite ici
alors que je pense que ce mandat devait
être un mandat d'apaisement sur les
héritant de l'interco les mariages
forcés et cetera voilà tout ça ça
devrait derri nous on sent aujourd'hui
que c'est un peu compliqué et ce ne sont
pas les interc qui sont remises en
question c'est le fait que on a beaucoup
d'élus qui sont loin des choses parce
qu'ils sont ils ne sont pas conseiller
communautaires que tout est complexe et
compliqué que on va parler du an du Zéro
artificialisation quand ça arrive au
final au conseiller
municipal qui qui doit gérer la pénuie
il peut même dire à son mère mais
comment tu nous as pas défendu ça crée
beaucoup de tension et que je pense que
tout ce qui peut amener à faire du lien
pour redécouvrir la valeur positive de
l'interco qui est un espace de
coopération pour faire mieux ensemble ce
qu'on peut pas faire tout seul je pense
que tout ça ça partici aussi de la
facilitation de l'engagement et de la
satisfaction tout ne sera pas dans la
loi je je peux peut-être me permettre de
prie mais avant de parler d'Interco
juste encore pour pour les professions
c'està dire pour les entreprises privées
on a aussi des difficultés avec des des
élus qui seront dans la fonction
publique et notamment l'éducation
nationale oui exact on a beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup d'élus qui sont enseignants
mais qui ont des des vraies difficultés
de crédidur qui doit être anticipé d'un
an c'est ça il faut qu'il sacheent et
que les horaires il faut que leur donne
des horaires réguliers me disent le
mercredi une fois par mois de de 20h ça
n'existe pas ça dans la vraie vie quoi
et donc ça c'est un vrai souci que je
rencontre auprès de mes mères sinon pour
l'intercommunalité évidemment
l'intercommunalité doit être
facilitateur mais doit permettre à
l'ensemble des élus municipaux de
participer aux travaux il faut
comprendre ce qu'on fait il faut
comprendre qu'une interco n'est pas là
pour se substituer elle est là pour
faire avec et donc il y a éminemment la
possibilité de créer du lien entre les
communes qui n'avaient pas envie d'être
ensemble on leur a dit un jour bah voilà
les ration nous ont dit que et on pense
vraiment que c'est bien pour vous donc
vous allez aller travailler avec eux euh
et et ça l'intercosubit c'est horrible
et et sur mulouse Jean-Marie bouquel a
beaucoup souffert de cela euh aucune
commune n'est venue de son propre gré je
veux dire aucune commune et ils étaient
là donc on les achète par des
attribution de compensation qu'on
négocié au début avec des transferts de
charges bon on sait faire ça tout le
monde sait faire c'est c'est des calculs
mais c'est pas ça qui va susciter la
confiance la confiance c'est comment je
construis mon mon territoire comment je
fais un développement économique comment
je travaille sur les réseaux de chaleur
comment est-ce que je je fais un
transfert de la compétence de l'eau en
gardant la possibilité moi en tant que
maire de dire ce qui se passe dans ma
commune comment je garde dans
l'urbanisme un plui qui doit être là
parce que bah c'est prescriptif au
niveau du SCOT et du stradet je veux
dire il faut qu'on soit en phase mais
que l'instruction puisse être faite par
le maire qui va encore décider de qui
veut avoir chez lui mais dans un la loi
SRU c'est pareil comment est-ce que moi
je peux
euh m'approprier les logements sociaux
si je suis un mare du de de d'une
commune de 500 habitants mais je suis
dans le même territoire donc je dois
être C cette fraternité entre les élus
c'est sur les bonnes choses les
mauvaises comment on peut les faire
ensemble et ça c'est le vrai rôle et au
niveau de l'administration c'est pareil
euh on a mis en place des secrétaires de
mairie à la disposition des communes des
services juridiques qui sont là le
marché des services publics et et c'est
ça qui est important au-delà de tous les
flux financiers c'est le lien qu'on doit
créer si on n'est pas en capacité de
créer les liens à travers
l'intercommunalité c'est que le
fonctionnement pas n'est pas celui qui
devait être et il y a des élus
communautaires sur mon agloon on en a
104 c'est déjà beaucoup je peux pas en
mettre 900 mais tous les 900 peuvent
participer à tous nos travaux je ne fais
pas un seul transfert de compéten sans
que je n'ai pas travailler avec
l'ensemble des élus municipaux et c'est
ça qui est imp et si on arrive à changer
ça bah du coup on devient facilitateur
on est acceptter et on travaille pour
l'avenir de nos communes merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président je pense pens
qu'ici vous vous
parlez voilà à des sénateurs qui sont
convaincus de cette vision de l'interco
qui est absolument indispensable quiire
enfin on devrait même plus dire que
c'est il est nécessaire c'est ancré dans
le pays mais que je pense que au final
on le sait bien la réussite ne vient pas
que des meilleures lois que nous pouvons
faire dans les meilleurs jours et des
meilleurs décrets d'application tout ça
s mis en œuvre par des hommes et des
femmes
pour de la population et que donc et
c'est la richesse et c'est ce qui fait
que nous nous engageons en tout cas
voilà je je voulais vous dire le réel
plaisir qui a été le N de de ce dialogue
oui je vous en prie Monsieur le
ma je voulais ajouter quelque chose je
vis pas partir frustré de cette non je
voudrais pas sur pas et donc de même
qu'il y a donc un dans les communes un
duo maire secrétaire de mairie et qui F
fonctionne depuis très très longtemps et
donc donc c'est au niveau parlementaire
effectivement il y a aussi une réflexion
sur la revalorisation des secrétaires de
mairie et donc moi je pense qu'il y a un
angle mort sur l'intercommunalité par
rapport à pour dire par rapport à à mon
collègue il y a la question l'angle mort
c'est que il n'existe pas ma
connaissance de formation pour les
personnel de l'interco à la gestion
communale ce que tu viens
d'indiquer je je ne l'ai pas vécu
c'est-à-dire que les les les gens qui
sont formés enfin les les les les agents
et même les directions direction général
des services ne sont pas du tout formés
à la coopération intercommunale pas je
rebondis pas sur fois vos propos et que
et que donc les les les les les les les
gens donc de mais là c'est pas c'est pas
que chez moi c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est multiplié donc je je déjà je te
félicite par rapport à ce que tu fais
mais mais c'est vrai que voilà il il y a
vraiment cette question là cet enjeu
donc un enjeu parallèle évidemment c'est
pas dans le périmètre de ce de ceon
discute ce matin mais par contre je je
tenais quand même àindiiquer je je vais
peut-être répondre euh je vous en prie
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
effectivement vrai il faut reformer
l'ensemble de l'administration à
travailler pour un ensemble de communes
quand on est à l'intercommunalité mais
c'est aussi vrai dans des communes je
veux dire Comand moi je suis arrivé dans
ma petite commune de 1200 habitants le
premier jour le secrétaire de mairie m'a
posé un signataire et il m'a dit bah un
parafeur il m'a dit bah voilà il faut
signer là en bas à droite quoi et donc
on a aussi l'administration qui a ce
pouvoir qu'on lui a laisser et qu'on lui
donne et à l'interco c'est le cas aussi
et justement on doit changer le système
et on a mis en place une collégiale des
DGS chez nous avec une rencontre
mensuelle de tous les secrétaires de
mairie pour partager pour porter avec
des référen pour être respectueux les
uns des autres l'un ne marche pas sans
l'autre et je j'ai ici j'ai ramené notre
projet de de pacte de gouvernance qu'on
a mis en place sur l'agglomération je
t'en laisserai naturellement et on en
est très fier parce que on a sauvé notre
aglo comme ça merci beaucoup pour ce
point je vous en prie Monsieur sachant
pour vous rassurer si je puis dire c'est
que nous allons sans doute dans cette
mandature alors nous on a des mandatures
de 3 ans parce que vous savez qu'au
Sénat il y a ce renouvellement partiel
et un des sujets qui revient beaucoup
aujourd'hui mais d'une manière positive
c'est de faire un un bilan du
fonctionnement de l'intercommunalité
enin interrogeant beaucoup sur ce qui
fait les conditions de la réussite et de
valoriser les bonnes pratiques c'est
c'est vraiment notre sujet donc on aura
l'occasion de vous retrouver et
d'échanger ça n'a pas un lien direct
avec le le sujet mais ça a un lien
énorme avec avec le bon fonctionnement
et donc la manière dont les élus peuvent
être épanouis parce que tout ça c'est
harmonieux oui je je je je vois l'heure
qui tourne et je pense qu'on va arriver
au stade de la de la fin de la de la de
la commission peut-être parce que sinon
on va se retrouver totalement entre nous
ce qui va être passionnant mais on va
perdre des auditeurs voilà et je voulais
je voulais juste juste vous vous
remercier et dire qu'effectivement c'est
c'est un sujet qui est très complexe
parce qu'il est dans l'équilibre entre
des des propositions très techniques
très précises et
euh un objectif très très très politique
au sens noble du terme par rapport à à
l'avenir de notre ocracie et
l'inquiétude qu'on a à la à la MF qui a
été exprimée par le président Lisnard et
et d'ailleurs relayé par le président
Larcher lors de son intervention c'est
l'articulation des calendriers euh il y
a une mission que le Président de la
République a
confié à Eric WZ avec un timing qui est
pas tout à fait celui qui correspond
nécessairement à un timing qui est celui
du du temps parlementaire et et à un
moment donné des décalages la crainte
c'est qu'effectivement tant que ce
rapport ne soit pas rendu il y ait pas
d'arbitrage et que donc effectivement on
reporte encore au Caland grec et et
quand je disais qu'on était à miimandat
tout à
l'heure pas encore un calendrier mais
les élections municipales en général se
tiennent en mars mars 2026 ça veut dire
que un an avant on tombe dans l'année
2024 ça veut dire que si effectivement
on n'est pas calé sur un calendrier de
l'année 2024 euh on risque de reporter
d'avoir une forme de dérapage ou de ou
de ou de glissement on va dire ça plus
diplomatiquement de glissement vers
effectivement autre chose et on risque
d'avoir après euh les les le
gouvernement qui va dire oui mais bon on
approche d'autres échéance et donc du
coup on verra ça après et donc on verra
ça après après après et donc il y a
vraiment urgence et donc nous portons
tous et particulièrement à la MF une
soixantaine 70 mesures euh qui qui qui
VO voilà qui vont du très technique à
des choses très très transversales on va
être attentif dans le débat que vous
avez évoqué d'ici le premier trimestre
on va dire de 2024 mais voilà je je
voulais attirer votre attention sur cet
enjeu qu'il y a effectivement parce que
la la situation elle est grave et
l'enquête qui a été menée auprès de plus
de 5000 maires par le sémipauvre traduit
effectivement cette cet enjeu qu'il y a
aujourd'hui à
agir le Parlement décidera les pri m
mais vraiment à agir parce que c'est
qume quelque chose qui qui est très
attendu et et qui doit aussi permettre
de construire une fin de mandat plus
apaisé euh et peut-être des futures
échéances électorales et notamment
municipales plus apaisé que dans le
contexte dans lequel nous sommes voilà
donc je voulais vous remercier préciser
cela merci pour votre euh question alors
moi je ne répondrai pas ni à la place du
gouvernement ni à la place du du
président du Sénat mais qui s'est lui
clairement exprimé au Congrès les maèes
il y a effectivement une mission qui est
conduite par Monsieur vert euh le
président du Sénat à la demande du
Président de la République cette mission
voilà le président du Sénat a désigné
suite à
l'interpellation du président de la
République de sénateurs pour travailler
avec Monsieur vert donc Mathieu
Darnaud et moi-même qui sommes ici un
binôme qui qui travaillant bon très
souvent sur les sujets de collectivité
donc nous avons eu notre première
rencontre hier euh voilà donc on va voir
comment on va organiser les travaux pour
que le maximum de collègues puissent à
un moment dire des choses voilà euh il y
a une autre mission qui a été désignée
je crois par la première ministre
avec Madame Vautrin euh et un autre édu
sur un peu la simplification bon moi je
me réjouis que que le gouvernement et
que le Président de la République disent
qu'il y a urgence agir pour que vous
puissiez agir c'est ça le sujet euh le
président de la République a posé un
diagnostic titre personnel je trouve
très juste maintenant c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quand on le fait et comment
on y va que le président du Sénat
affirme dans un esprit qui n'est pas du
tout un esprit d'opposition au
gouvernement c'est pas l'esprit du du du
du président du sa mais il dit VO nous
on sait que c'est urgent on a des tas
d'idées on a déjà des tas de travaux
parce qu'on travaille là-dessus depuis
des années les associations d'lieux ont
chacune fait un travail considérable et
assez convergent donc nous Sénat nous
sommes le pouvoir législatif donc on a
une indépendance par rapport au pouvoir
exécutif mais on n'est pas du tout en
opposition bien et que donc nous nous
annonçons un calendrier c'est qu'en
janvier nous nous porterons enfin sera
déposé une proposition de loi ensuite
donc nous nous allons être proactif nous
n'attendons pas il appartiendra au
gouvernement de voir comment il se
saisit des travaux du Sénat pour avancer
nous avons fait au mois de mai ou juin
une proposition loi donc avec donc le
président de la commission des lois les
présidents de groupe de la majorité
sénatoriale moi-même au titre de la
délégation et mon collègue Mathieu
Larnaud qui est aujourd'hui
viceprésident du Sénat nous avons déposé
une une proposition de loi sur la
protection des élus parce que il y avait
enfin rappelez-vous enfin quand je avais
le feu pardonnez-moi et nous on a dit on
on agit on l'a fait le gouvernement a
repris notre proposition qui doit passer
à l'Assemblée au mois de janvier donc
ensuite il appartiendra au gouvernement
qui est le le gouvernement c'est
l'exécutif d'avancer et de voir mais
nous tous nos travaux sont transparents
par rapport à Monsieur vert je rappelle
que il y a eu des propositions qui ont
été faites par le président Larcher en
juillet issu d'un groupe très
transpartisan donc voilà nous nous
sommes pas là en compétition sur ligne
de course avec le gouvernement parce que
nous pensons comme vous qu'il faut agir
et c'est
maintenant et c'est maintenant et qu'il
n'y a pas de temps à perdre parce que je
pense qu'il faudrait que à la fin de
2024 il y a un texte sur ce qu'on
appelle le statut de l'lu mais aussi un
texte sur d'autres éléments et nous nous
continuons à avancer sur le sujet de ce
qu'on appelle la décentralisation et la
différenciation donc soyez assuré de la
détermination du du président Larché de
la manière dont nous je dis la première
mission qu'on a faite on a été
reconstitué c'était quand les 5 octobre
18 octobre et nous allons rendre 2 mois
après même avant puceque ce sera le le
14 cette mission flash des élus elle
n'aura pas ét été faite à la légère
parce qu'on s'est Nour tous vos travaux
voilà vous nous avez tout dit euh il y a
eu beaucoup d'auditions il y a eu les
enquête que vous avez faite et nous
avions déjà sur l'étagère comme dit le
président Larcher un certain nombre
d'idées et de propositions voilà et
naturellement euh euh nous nous nous
sommes heureux de de ce travail avec euh
avec les associations parce que c'est
notre état d'esprit nous devons avancer
d'une manière conjointe et forte parce
qu'on a aussi euh c'est pas une conquête
de l'opinion publique à faire mais à
expliquer à l'opinion publique ce que
sera la vie sans un
maire et que le maire il doit être
respecté il doit être soutenu euh et
l'État doit doit doit l'affirmer et
qu'il appartient à chacun de pouvoir
être candidat aux élections et de les
gagner donc voilà merci vraiment
beaucoup je propose qu'on fasse une
photo avec les corapporteurs si vous
voulez merci et puis naturellement à
bientôt pour un nouvel épisode mais nous
pensons que la saga doit avoir une fin
voilà faut commettre un acte merci voilà
on va faire